South Korean government plans to
increase
the maximum working hours to 69 and
allow for banking overtime in exchange
for time off replacing the 52-hour work
week law introduced in 2018 the new
proposal aims to provide more
flexibility in the labor market
promoting family growth and Improvement
of fertility rate projected Toyota
Global low of 0.7 in 2024 employers and
workers would agree on whether to count
overtime by the week month quarter half
year full year up to 29 hours a week of
overtime allowed for periods a month or
longer over 29 hours of overtime can be
exchanged later for time off of
unspecified raid while the government
argues that allowing workers to spend
accrued overtime on vacations will
enable people who want to work less such
as parents or caregivers to do more to
do so some experts are skeptical about
the proposal's ability to reduce working
hours time what do you think about this
article
um if they're trying to get people to
work longer and solve the fertility rate
I think they got they're trying to burn
that candle at both ends
I don't think that works I think
somewhere someplace in government the
maximum work week is 69 hours so that
would be if you looked at an American
40-hour week that's 29 hours of overtime
so maybe that's working eight on
Saturday extra five hours every day
that's a lot of overtime
um so I I you know I don't know I
proposed more flexibility in the labor
market it sounds like it's less
flexibility because you're you're
working more and improve the fertility
rate because you're never home I don't
know how that works yeah I agree with
Tom on this I'm did I'm doing the math
on this by the way 69 but this this
seems like a number Elon Musk would make
his employers work like yeah I want you
uh clocking in at 4 20 and you work 69
hours uh a week wink wink
um it seems very Elon muskish but 69
hours divided by five days if that's how
often you choose to work that's 14 hours
a day okay and we all know that you only
get four hours of sleep these days so
that's that's the number right there's
you only have a certain amount of time
to do your thing 69 divided by six days
is 11 and a half hours if you do the 52
hours a week divided by five that's ten
hours a day I think this is an ongoing
conversation that we continue to have
you know the the work life balance the
four day work week which you just did a
great
um episode on that on valuetainment and
then you know the bigger question do you
live to work or work to live and uh have
you seen the trending topic on on Tick
Tock these days about this um
it's like uh uh like Moody Mondays or
something like that I'll find the story
but it's basically like how young people
don't necessarily have to work on
Mondays have you seen that no and I'll
find you this thing
but but you could pull up the fertility
rate I sent you right now countries take
a look at this time lowest in the world
is Taiwan then South Korea Singapore
Macau Hong Kong
I mean top five
all in Asia right oh bare minimum Monday
is what it's called by the way bare
minimum Monday which is what that's the
trending thing on Tick Tock right now
go to the Puerto Rico
I mean how is Puerto Rico so low the
people in Puerto Rico are beautiful like
that should be like 4.8 right
um
British Virgin Island Bosnia Romania
Japan Greece Greece they don't even work
you have all the time to make babies
Poland Portugal Croatia one of the most
beautiful cities on Earth there what
were the stats that we did the other day
about talking about
you said where's the most beautiful
women in the world and you said it
wasn't a city you went to Dubrovnik
Croatia yeah there's no way Croatia is
on that list 1.44
well listen you know when I wasn't
married and I was single my favorite
place to go read books was Croatia
incredible libraries okay so Andorra
Slovakia
Hungary these are some low numbers
you know by the way put the highest
fertility rate flip it let's see what
the highest fertility these are for the
lowest fertility lowest not having kids
not having kids all right not having
kids
oh is it in Mexico
highest fertility rate
by countries what wow 6.9 wow makes
sense
go a lot of is in Africa zooming yeah
Somalia 6.0
all Africa yeah it's all Africa well
when you have no economy you have time
on your hand look at this South Korea
the lowest fertility rates there it is
that's why they're implementing this so
so can you can you go back to see if the
list goes even higher like what they
need is a lot of Africa
but they had a they had a lockdown Tom
no no not this one that only shows top
10 that's where you are go to another
one to see if we can go even lower
yeah like I want to see more than just
10. no this one's only going to give you
a few
what's the highest
zoom in see if we see anything
uh Somali one would keep going lower
keep going lower you know Afghanistan
4.72
Sudan Zambia Cameroon yeah I mean that's
pretty wild to be at 0.9
so I don't I don't understand the
correlation with the amount of hours you
work do you know why
I mean dude I don't know how many people
like work you know like I work I have
four kids like you mean to tell me you
don't have time to make babies
wow well the more you work the less time
for leisure
so that that is that is that doesn't
make any sense you know why that doesn't
make any sense okay Greece is known as
the lowest of working hours uh one of
the lowest working hours in the country
they don't work that many hours they're
not even making kids so the correlation
to me doesn't make any sense well go
back to that thing about South Korea
they're the lowest in fertility yet they
want to increase the working
right
I just pulled up this article Psychology
today why does South Korea have the
lowest fertility rate in the world okay
it says the vast majority of young
couples in South Korea end up having one
child because of high child car child
care costs young couples also have delay
having children because of expensive
housing to increase fertility rate South
Korean government should Implement
long-term plans to reduce Child Care and
housing costs okay so that's the reason
why they're they're making it more
affordable to have a family there's no
way it's because you don't have time
there's no way you don't have time I
mean how many go to the Fortune 500
company CEOs how do they have all these
kids well they got money housing and uh
but their work is not a concern it's
it's yeah exactly so it's got nothing to
do with the number of hours you work why
do soldiers have so many kids
you know it has to do with money it has
to do with other than it's not just
about you don't have time it doesn't
take 22 hours to have sex
I mean it it's it it's a if you do I
mean it's respect
good job can you imagine like yeah no
that he he definitely wasn't a 22 hour
guy who hit us twenty thousand numbers
he was more like a two-minute guy yeah
hit it and quitter that was like 20 000
is a tough number to get McDonald's
drive through Manny I think interesting
here here I like where you went with
this Pat by the way I'm focusing more on
the work component you're the more
focused on the fertility
it comes down to money FTM follow the
money that's what it comes down to huh
it comes down to money and culturally
what you're saying okay religion culture
like I don't know the philosophies of
what what they what they're teaching
from the top whatever the influence at
the top is saying they're gonna do okay
whatever you know how we looked at the
Muslim Church Muslim denomination how
many kids they're having versus
Christians yeah it's not even close it
comes from the top whatever they're
saying at the top they're doing Mormons
what are Mormons known for what's the
joke about Mormons they got 20 wives
yeah and not not the wives part but
that's the first place you go to oh yeah
I don't know where were you going like a
fantasy for you
somebody has six kids what do they say
you must be a more oh yeah right because
they from the top they're having a lot
of kids this has got nothing to do my
opinion I don't think the primary factor
is so uh I think it's other other things
not the number of hours they're working
per week but it's a good good way to
spin it if people want to spin it so if
you like this clip and you want to watch
another one click right here and if you
want to watch the entire podcast click
right here
[Music]